good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-4431
containment class euclid
disruption class vlam
and risk class warning
special containment procedures
research station 5 has been built
directly above scp-4431-a
seismometers across antarctica will
monitor activity from scp-4431-a
and report any irregularities in the
anomalies behavior at least one boring
probe and an ice sheet drilling
mechanism are to be kept at the station
in the event that investigation of
scp-4431-a
is necessary
contact is to be maintained with all
foundation and non-foundation research
stations in antarctica for reports of
scp-4431-b manifestations if a
manifestation is reported personnel at
the station are advised to monitor the
manifestation and resultant
scp-4431c instances objects left by
expired instances are to be transported
to the nearest foundation facility
mobile task force psy-1 dispatch from
miskatonic will be deployed for
containment if necessary non-foundation
personnel that witness these anomalies
will be administered appropriate
amnestics on leaving antarctica
cover stories regarding the dayton
bannered antarctic expedition have been
disseminated reporting the expedition
ship as having vanished on route to the
filter ice shelf as surviving personal
accounts from banner describe a wide
variety and number of anomalous
phenomena beyond scp-4431
all information on the expedition has
been acquired by the foundation
potential links between the events of
the expedition and
scp-4431-a's current activity are of
high concern
description
scp-4431 designates two subterranean
artificial structures
scp-4431 a and b and a collection of
psionic organisms designated scp-4431c
present in east antarctica
scp-4431-a is a machine located 3400
meters below the antarctic plateau
buried in the bedrock under the east
antarctic ice sheet the object's depth
renders it undetectable by ice
penetrating radar preventing full
analysis of its appearance in size
current size estimates include a minimum
width of 20 kilometers as drilling
investigations to examine the structure
and variably end in failure refer to
discovery no further information on
scp-4431-a
is known
scp-4431-b
is a cylindrical tunnel constructed from
a rhodium platinum alloy with a 11 meter
interior radius the tunnel extends for
39 meters before reaching a sharp
vertical drop which descends for a
distance estimated to be a minimum of
3000 meters scp-4431-b
will manifest in a region of the
antarctic plateau on a bi-monthly basis
rising out of the terrain until a
majority of its entrance is exposed a
variable number of scp-4430
instances will then exit often between
one or seven after a period of time
ranging from eight hours to three days
scp-4431-b demanifests retracting into
the ground connection with tracking
devices placed on the structure during
demanifestation are all lost after two
hours preventing observation of
scp-4431-b's relocation
the body structure of scp-4431c
instances can vary though consistent
details have been determined these
details are as follows
one meter tall upright conical bodies
with the main body and each limb
segmented in a manner similar to
arthropods the main body is divided into
three sections
four or more legs attached to the base
of the body
variable numbers have three meter long
tendrils on the body's midsection each
ending in a claw
a toroidal mass covered in small unknown
biological structures fixed around the
top of the body presumed to be a form of
sensory organ
a set of mandibles on the bottom of the
cone
anatomical deviations tend to include
features that aid in withstanding
antarctic conditions or other purposes
tumorous growths acting as heat
radiators have been observed along with
cybernetic flamethrower implants many
instances possess conical protrusions on
their body which open to dispense
environmental monitoring devices rarely
instances are found with the tops of
their bodies replaced by antennas and
clusters of spherical machinery that
serve similar purposes following
scp-4431-b manifestation
scp-4431-c instances will attempt to
construct makeshift structures from any
surrounding materials presumably
intended to be shelters instances
typically expire in a few hours from
environmental factors the ones brought
into containment have an average
lifespan of 11 hours primary cause of
death is the gradual degradation of
internal organs following this all
organic matter on the instance dissolves
into a bright pink fluid hereafter
referred to as hemorrhoids
instances possess psionic abilities used
for the manipulation of objects
surroundings and entities limited
telepathic communication has been
displayed on occasion
information on the suspected origins of
scp-4431
is restricted
addendum 4431
want
discovery
the first reports of
scp-4431 are from 1919 when an antarctic
expedition led by former british naval
officer dayton bannard repeatedly
encountered scp-4431-b
and c instances refer to addendum 4431
1. accounts of scp-4431-b
manifestations continued after the first
antarctic research stations were
established leading to
scp-4431-b and c being classified as
anomalies in the year 2000.
scp-4431-a came to the attention of the
foundation in march of 2019 when
foundation personnel operating at
research outpost 2 in the antarctic
plateau detected abnormal seismic
activity originating from an underground
location based on foundation simulations
of earth's tectonic plate movement it
was determined that this could be the
possible location of a ring-shaped lake
depicted on scp-2651-a
presuming it was not destroyed by
geologic activity and prehistoric
k-class events after approximately 700
million years plans for excavation were
proposed when the source of the activity
triangulated to a region 10 kilometers
in radius
in june of 2019 a specialized boring
probe was sent through the ice sheet and
drilled into the bedrock attaining a
depth of 3400 meters before entering a
cavern with an oxygen-rich atmosphere
and contacting a metal surface images
from the probe show the surface to be
covered in an array of mechanical
appendages that were in the process of
excavating the cavern ceiling all
readings from the probe were lost an
hour after contact retrieval attempts
failed due to the sudden collapse of the
sub-bedrock section of the borehole and
the formation of the frozen hemorrhoids
in within the main drilling mechanism
all subsequent drilling investigations
have experienced similar outcomes
scp-4431-a was registered as an anomaly
in august of 2019 of note is that since
the first drilling investigation the
number of recorded
scp-4431-b manifestations has increased
addendum 4431 2
dayton banner journal excerpts
the following are relevant excerpts from
the personal journal of dayton bannard
written during his expedition to reach
the south pole bannard failed to keep
dates for a majority of entries and the
excerpts are suspected to have been
written during spring of early 1919
recovered photographs are included
bernard 4431 excerpts
1.
searching for giles was a fruitless
endeavor the snow had been piling up for
hours ruining any footprints and not a
soul could be seen on the horizon in
such heavy blue twilight i shouted for
him in vain attempts before i gave up
and went back to base by the time i
returned the snow had piled up high
enough by our ramshackle hut and i had
to dig my way in
i shot the door behind me and there was
silence no sounds from my crew members
nor the gusts outside only the creeks of
wood as i moved then i heard it a
constant clicking that started up
stopped and kept repeating i crept
towards the main room's entrance peeking
around the corner and suddenly freezing
in place a hole was in one of the walls
fully plugged up with snow and standing
in the center was a beast i can barely
begin
to describe its body was a cone resting
on four spider-like legs whipped like
limbs swirling around it a ring-shaped
thing resting on top i nearly screamed
then and there
my heart was racing as its body swayed
and stumbled towards me i felt a
splitting headache and then a voice rang
out in my head
this voice so much unlike a voice i may
as well not describe it as such said a
single word
home
the beast's body then softened like a
cracker being dipped in water collapsing
apart into a foul-smelling pink fluid
there was a sudden tremor and then the
walls around buckled i rested in that
snow for what felt like an eternity
praying to god
once the crew pulled me to my feet they
told me that the beast had barged in
through the wall while i was out
prompting everyone to hide where they
could nobody saw what it did before i
returned
once we started eating psy started to
panic he kept asking over and over again
if the beast was some type of demon
wondering if he heard the voice of the
devil himself i suspect he heard the
same voice i did
i wish i had an answer
when we had fully awoken richard
proposed we go out and find where the
beast had come from we were all
apprehensive at first psy being the most
nervous among us but after a long
discussion we realized we had little
else to do until lewin's crew returns
with supplies when the snow finally
stopped piling up we went out to survey
the area for any abnormalities
the first several hours met with no
discoveries until i heard abner
hollering by a cave entrance nothing
peculiar struck me when i first entered
but as i went in further i noticed what
abner was obsessing over at the cave's
rear at the bottom of a long downwards
incline fashioned into what seemed like
a staircase was a cavernous tunnel not
composed of ice or rock but of perfectly
smooth metal the likes of which i have
never seen before it stretched out
further than any light could reach there
is no doubt in my mind that this is
where the beast came from
i awoke to the sound of splintering wood
in a thunderous crash the wood that made
up much of the hot ceiling buckled under
the weight of continued snowfall and
dropped a dense wall of snow into the
main room thankfully shelton who had
been sleeping there was far enough to
one side that we were easily able to dig
him out after hours of digging we were
able to form tunnels connecting with all
areas of the hut but we know that this
will not work as a shelter much longer
richard has been adamant that we use the
cave stating that it's our only chance
at survival we all wish that didn't have
to be the case
but as i look at the walls around me i
fear that they will collapse a moment
too soon
in a few hours time the eight of us will
hold the vote on our course of action
all i know is that turning back will not
be an option
we unanimously voted to use the cave i
can tell that none of us are enthused by
this especially psy who is failing
hiding his nervousness under an
emotionless veneer but by now
the den of a monster is more inviting
than death under mounds of snow the
snowfall has stopped and we will depart
in a few hours time
so far the tunnel has proven a good fit
for our survival the constant heat flows
out of it warming the air to the point
that richard was able to not wear any
protective clothing 10 meters into it
none of this air escapes far into the
cave relegating us to an eerie darkness
i've dared not go near that pit at the
tunnel's end on multiple occasions i
swear i've heard clicking noises but
whenever i ask
it turns out to have only been myself
richard has been acting
strangely a statement that seems
redundant but is more true than ever
before every couple of hours he wraps
seven times on the tunnel walls goes out
for what he says are brief strolls only
to carve more esoteric symbols into the
cave's eyes he seems happier than i've
ever seen him i've always thought of him
to be a mystic who had largely shed his
roots for a nobler educated life but now
as i watch him i highly doubt this
notion
as abner does his best to keep morale up
by roping everyone into improvised
theater performances i find myself going
to the edge of the pit away from the
laughter and commotion to sit with my
own thoughts i tossed the small
religious pendant giles left behind in
there and carefully listened for it to
hit the bottom a few slight tinks
against the metal walls then silent all
i heard was just my heartbeat the light
from the lamp i bring along is barely
provided enough to let me see the walls
of this massive structure so i have no
idea of how far down it goes
occasionally richard will join me he
silently walks in and sits a bit farther
behind me gazing off into nothing we've
never exchanged this single word here to
us it's a sacred place to be alone with
our thoughts and i dare not disturb that
peace for anyone he's far braver than i
am and turning off his lamp whenever he
arrives though i always pointlessly fear
that at some point that shadows will
pull me away leaving the rest of the
crew on their own and this lamp is my
safeguard against it or perhaps i worry
that in darkness i'll stumble and fall
to my death whatever the reason with
this light i make the things
i've seen
on the voyage feel less real
we woke up to find that richard was gone
his sleeping bag was open with much of
his equipment left behind abner checked
the cave and couldn't find any new marks
in the snow so he had to have still been
in the tunnel after a moment of
preparation to retrieve lamps we started
going deep into the tunnel minutes later
i turned around to see that everyone had
stopped following me several meters back
i ordered them to come forward but they
simply stood there doing nothing i
decided to go on without them reaching
the edge of the abyss after what felt
like
hours i reached the edge solely hearing
the rattling of my lamp and the
quickening of my heartbeat all that i
could find was richard's boots and a
single lit lamp i looked about all over
hoping i would see him elsewhere in the
darkness but he was nowhere he'd fallen
in i cursed the heavens and stomped the
ground kicked his lamp with a great
swing of the foot
and watched its light tumble down till
it vanished when i came out i told the
crew he'd left without a trace
eventually i came to ask why they had
stopped following me despite my clear
orders quietly when no one else would
speak palmer told me that they had begun
fearing for their own lives they saw one
of the beasts clinging to the ceiling
directly above me
i can't return to the pit anymore i look
down there and swear i see the
flickering of light i look up the walls
and swear i see shifting symbols and
shapes
and when i close my eyes and look
nowhere i still see something a ring a
halo suspended in the colorless region
under my eyelids the last time i went
today i started hearing that godforsaken
noise that clicking of the beasts
i peered past the edge and my lamp
snuffed out whether by my negligence to
check the fuel
or something else
i stood there for moments paralyzed and
i came to a terrible realization every
time i had been here the only sound to
keep me company would be my heartbeat
and interspersed gaseous noises from the
lamp
that sound was not my heartbeat
i spun around right as the voices grew
from faint whispers to murmurs and i ran
dropping the lamp and only stopping when
i seen the lights of my crew
tomorrow i will inform the crew of a new
rule nobody is allowed further than 10
meters away from the tunnel entrance
that hole can only lead to further woes
bernard 4431 excerpts 2.
when i returned from outside and reached
the stairwell i saw the crew outside the
tunnel pressing themselves up against
the cavern walls to either side of the
entrance i was about to ask what was
happening when palmer signaled me to be
quiet and moved to the far wall the crew
isn't idiotic so i knew they had a good
reason for this and i quickly followed
his command silence it first then
scraping then clicking i went behind a
pillar of ice and peered out to see
three beasts climb up the staircase two
left the cavern while one with massive
bulges on its body froze in place one of
the bulges cracked and it shattered
dropping a black sphere the beast then
left to join its companions
once i knew they were gone i went to
inspect the sphere they left which had a
crude stick figure of a human on it i
tapped it with my foot and it split in
half revealing a growing mass of some
sort of pale flesh-like foam that
quickly became larger than myself
eventually it stopped growing and rested
there pulsating
i've been in the tunnel since unwilling
to interact with this thing for the time
being
the foam is food we were on one of our
last cans of good meat when psy threw
his to the ground shattered about how he
was sick of it and then ran out of the
tunnel and out the staircase we chased
after him we couldn't let what giles did
repeat and saw his face buried in the
foam chewing like a mad animal he pulled
his head out to tell us how great it
tasted then plunged back in none of us
knew what to do at first shaw simply
shrugged
then joined in and over time the rest of
us did too it was the most nourishing
meal i've had in ages
we pay the beasts far less mind now we
will still go quiet when three or more
of them march past us in the tunnel but
they have harmed us not not even a
single voice has been heard every two
days a new food sphere is dropped even
with the other ones being far from
replenished outside the beasts
continually drop strange objects and
apparatuses until they melt into the
snow at which point a new group emerges
to repeat the process
palmer abner and i have tried to
understand what these devices do but
their nearly monolithic designs elude us
the twilight continues to haunt us
certainly it will always be the case
until the daylight months return but
antarctica has come to feel less
treacherous i will continue to keep my
guard though for the sake of my crew i
won't allow us to be caught when we are
vulnerable
something impossible happened last night
prior to me falling asleep so i write
this the following day we heard the
familiar clanging noises of the beasts
as a new group was nearing the tunnel
exit but there was a difference
i have grown accustomed to hearing the
rhythmic noises they make when moving
across metal so when i heard an entirely
different set of sounds
i was disturbed
coming out of the tunnel flanked on both
sides by two beasts was something only
vaguely human it moved on mechanical
legs six many jointed silver arms
dangling the seventh arm emerging from
its chest pointed forward the torso was
hidden under a tattered blood-stained
coat and a mask of ice that refused to
melt obscured its face
the creature shambled over to me and
spoke in a voice like faulty typewriters
introducing itself as richard parish
by that point i was certain i was
dreaming so i welcomed him back and then
fell asleep when i woke up in the
morning i was not prepared to see him
truly exist
i'd be lying if i said that none of us
were in shock at richard's return he
acts as though he never left only
alluding to changes when he calls
himself an
ambassador for man whenever i ask about
what happened to him in the pit he
becomes silent only talking again when
the conversation shifts to a different
topic never has he taken off the mask
saying it's best it stays on
his behavior has also become even more
peculiar he accompanies the beasts when
they leave to drop their devices then he
uses his arms to open the machines and
apparently inspect them he continues to
do the seven knocks on metal ritual but
now it's accompanied by his own clicking
sounds i am certain that the objects he
carves with his symbols now glow in the
darkness it is faint but i know it's
there when nothing else is happening
he'll ramble about nonsensical subjects
while i can understand the sentences
about how everyone should be bleeding
i can't trust him
i mustn't
in the afternoon or at least what felt
like it i assembled abner and palmer for
what i told the crew was a survey of the
outside to find the best route for the
expedition in reality we went to check
the devices richard was returning to the
tunnel when we left so we knew that not
a soul would see us
the target of our investigation was a
cubic machine it had an array of limbs
that stabbed the snow and pumped her
brown fluid into it staining the area
the three of us tried to pull a limb out
of the ground then tried to hoist the
entire object but we found that it was
firmly stuck in place abner spotted a
panel on one side and opened it exposing
some sort of spherical contraption
surrounded by wires on the inside
messing with the interior of a
potentially dangerous mechanism was a
terrible idea so we started digging up
the snow around it
the ice was wholly being replaced by
some form of pale purple dirt blue plant
things sprouting in it palmer rushed
over to a near identical object dug
around and found more purple dirt and
blue plants for an hour we watched the
ice transmute into dirt and sprout
plants like nothing i've heard of even
small slug-like creatures began to take
form from fluids in the soil we returned
to the tunnel an hour later
recently psy has taken an interest in
richard's nonsense he'll sit by him
listening to every word he says like a
student with their teacher i swear i've
seen him take notes on a scrap of paper
once today when richard started the
knocking he joined in and now they are
repeating the same chants as i write i
haven't seen him scared at the sight of
a beast since psy may be the youngest
but he isn't idiotic that much i know if
he is willing to listen and follow along
with the occult then there must be a
reason for it what such a reason could
be
escapes me
i was returning from a brief look
outside when richard approached me
telling me that he had questions he led
me to a section of the cave away from
the tunnel and asked me why palmer abner
and i keep leaving to inspect the
machines he saw us i said i was only
interested in what they were doing in as
calm of a manner as i could muster like
a faulty record he started asking if i
meant harm incessantly i kept responding
with no but as he asked i began doubting
how true my answer was
he abruptly paused placed a hand on my
shoulder and asked if i realized the
importance the beasts held i was so out
of my wits that i was silent he said
that if i was interested in the machines
i should be joining him in his rituals
he claimed that it would be an
enlightening experience for everyone and
a path with more opportunities than
heading for the south pole i nearly lost
my nerve and shouted about how far we
had come since we departed and how
renowned we would be upon returning
he sighed said that it was pointless to
be in the shadow of amundsen when there
was a higher purpose below
then left for the tunnel
whether by our digging that exposed the
dirt or by the whims of the machines the
dirt has replaced at least half an acre
the plants have become spore spewing
pillars and the slugs as large as my
feet occasionally dividing like cells or
inflating into zeppelin creatures that
fly to the horizon and out of sight the
other machines seem to be helping the
growth releasing dirt making fluid and
foam for the animals the beasts simply
perform inspections and leave devices
farther out into the tundra it is
reassuring that the expansion seems to
have slowed down but the amount of life
here is constantly increasing it's as if
every time i turn to look some new type
of slug or plant has been born
the situation at the tunnel seems to be
equally deteriorating psy isn't alone
sure shelton and esben are all involved
in hourly rituals they barely notice
when i call out to them more intent on
every move richard makes and his talk of
impossible stars bleeding gods and
world-sized corpses the only one to pay
me any mind is espen initially i was
afraid by how nonsensical richard seemed
to be
now i'm afraid that the nonsense is true
i'm not one to keep logs of dreams
but this one has happened so often and
is recalled so clearly that i must write
it down
it starts with seven points of light in
darkness one point cracks and bleeds
pink liquid which coalesce into a thin
glowing ring then there is a planet the
details of which are just false the ring
emerges on the planet and stays until
the planet cracks a second planet
covered in what i think are green oceans
appears and the ring emerges again
something made of flesh rises on it and
the planet vanishes replaced by another
covered in purple soil with the pink
ring on it a hole opens and the ring
appears above antarctica
a week ago when i heard the voice i
didn't know why it said home surely the
home of such a monstrosity would be long
ways off from here down in the
underworld where it belongs it had to
have been confused now i realize demons
are far too human for what these are
i woke up last night while everyone was
sleeping after feeling something rub
against my back standing overhead was
richard reading my journal and dripping
the damn pink blood out of his mask as
he did so he'd reached behind my back
into my sleeping bag and pulled it out i
tried to stay as still as possible
provide an illusion of slumber minutes
that felt like years passed and he
dropped the journal in front of me
stepping over me and walking deeper into
the tunnel once i was sure he'd left i
reached to pull my journal back to
safety when a metal hand slammed down
onto mine i was dragged out of my bed
i've forgotten the rest
it isn't safe here anymore i won't write
until it is
bernard 4431 excerpts 3.
earlier today i awoke abner and palmer
to tell them about last night's events
there was no doubt we had to move
everyone else was sleeping and i had
seen richard go deep into the tunnel
with two beasts so he quietly packed
whatever supplies we could palmer
accidentally woke espen who we told
would be departing to survey the land
though esvin was luckily sane he pleaded
to come with us saying that the rituals
richard started seemed entertaining at
first
but are now incredibly disturbing
although i am wary i brought him along
more hands on deck is always better
our track outside was uneventful though
the ecosystem the beasts have been
creating with the dirt is now
flourishing the amount of plants has
increased to the point where much of the
purple ground is covered in strange
yellows and blues insects would scurry
out of our path before i could get a
good look at them and the slugs now as
large as horses were feasting on the
remains of something long we were all
happy to be out of there i'm currently
writing this within the hut we abandoned
i don't know how long it will stay
standing once it does fall i don't know
where we will go our supplies will last
us for a few days but when they run out
i know lewin's crew will be too far away
to aid us
god help me
when we left yesterday someone had to
have been listening to our move through
one of the windows i can see richard
shaw shelton and psy standing side by
side in the distance i think they are
watching the hut i told the crew we'll
be staying on guard
[Music]
it's an hour later richard shaw and psy
have left for the cave shelton seemed to
fall in the snow and vanish i
occasionally see brief movement under
the snow
but it feels like my mind is playing
tricks on me
an hour after my last entry shelton
broke into the hut i heard the
shattering of glass and i found that he
had lunged through the window at abner
trying to strangle him i kicked him off
and the four of us got him restrained
and tied up to a chair his skin had
paled since we last saw him and a metal
cylinder worn to the touch had been
embedded in his chest we tried to get
him out to talk but much like richard he
went quiet
and stared nowhere
es-ben then knelt down by the chair
whispered a sentence in the language
richard was so fond of
and he started shaking he told us that
richard wanted to speak with me a
statement he kept repeating again and
again either that was all his brain let
him say or he needed to keep quiet about
something else mid-sentence he went
quiet gurgled a bit then his whole head
started to melt and sink below the
collar of his jacket like a heated wax
statue of his whole body liquefied and
all that remained was a pool of pink
blood
after much deliberation i will head out
to meet with richard i can see him from
the window standing at the edge of the
ecosystem if i don't return i'll leave
abner in charge of what little remains
of the expedition he'll make it to the
pole in my honor
i survived when i arrived the only
people there was cyan richard i was
hoping that pink blood stains wouldn't
be obvious on my clothes but now i
inspect them it's clear they could see
it they knew what happened richard made
some sort of noise a chuckle and he said
that they did not mean the world harm
that after this shaky start it would
improve
richard's body for lack of accurate
words unfolded his body spasmed open and
a cylindrical spire shot out of the
fractured remains growing like a
deranged plant i recoiled with psy
taking the chance to start choking me
not noticing the axe i had brought i'm
cleaning the viscera off it as i write
once the regrettable deed was done it
was far too late for richard though the
spire was thicker than his entire torso
and was growing by the second pulling
the rest of his mass and the surrounding
terrain inwards with twisted metal
tendrils every single apparatus the
creatures had left behind was pulled in
and incorporated into its mass with
similarly shaped protrusions forming on
the sides the last words i heard from
him were protect existence his head was
pulled in with a sickening crunch right
after
all i could do was run the rest of the
day has been spent with the crew
watching from the camp in horror as the
tower grows taller than the highest
steeples the antarctic night is setting
in and the bright red lights are
flickering along the tower's sides
the next seven pages consist of drawings
it is unknown what many of the drawings
represent though several have been
identified as scp-4431c
instances vehicles resembling those
found at martian impact crater herschel
unknown organisms and sketches depicting
the tower previously described the only
text present is the word spreading
under those unearthly lights of the
flora and tower i can spot someone
entering a vehicle almost like their
tanks my military friends spoke of
unless they are operated in unimaginable
ways
these will be our best chance
first priority is halting the beasts i
won't let myself be responsible for not
ending this when i had the chance
god gave us strength
in the morning the crew and i gathered
any tools that could serve as weapons
and our best supplies then set out to
the tower with science shelton dead and
richard effectively gone the only
dangers would be the beasts the
creatures of the ecosystem and shore as
we moved the beasts levitating around
the tower's exterior and adjusting its
external machinery
melted into a pink rain which i hoped
had rid us of one more problem
once we entered the ecosystem much of
the fauna ignored us more interested in
violently attacking each other or mating
in bizarre manners
after several minutes we finally saw the
tank up close the vehicle's main mass is
a sideways x-shaped contraption with
large treads attached on either side
above each tread is a massive mechanical
structure reminding me of the bulky
front limbs and claws of crabs
problems emerged right as we reached it
shaw opened the tank's hatch and stepped
out noticed us then began shouting as
ben shouted something back before being
pushed against the tank by an invisible
force two men each with bodies built
like richards but with the exact same
face as shelton stepped around the
tank's edge and babbled in more of that
language before running towards us abner
fired his rifle but the same force made
the bullets slow and drop like stones
palmer made a similar attempt by
throwing his lamp but it was tossed far
off behind them breaking and starting a
fire
when they were pressed against the side
as well i was certain i was done for but
they froze and stared at me they were
waiting for me to make a move to have a
reason to retaliate my body was freezing
and without shelter inside the vehicle i
would perish panicking i scurried around
looking for anything i could use when i
found a small slug likely only recently
spawned disregarding any rational
thought i grabbed it and threw it at one
of the shelton duplicates who didn't so
much as flinch the slug emitted a
gurgling screech and a larger entity
shambled out of the darkness resembling
one of the slugs
but standing on spindly legs its head
split open into massive tentacles and
the shelton was pulled into its more
espin and abner fell onto the ground and
rushed to open the hatch
the last shelton pulled me toward them
folding their mouth open and releasing a
long silver structure in a stroke of
luck i still had the ice axe on me and
once i reached them i could save myself
from whatever fate awaited me i crashed
onto the ground and sprinted for the
hatch which espen had holding open as
palmer got in when i reached it one of
the blasted beasts suddenly emerged from
the darkness wrapping its tendrils
around the door edges and grabbing onto
poor esbin he was whipped off into the
darkness screaming until a series of
metal scrapes and wet cracking sounds
rang out
i shut the hatch and the area instantly
warmed in a stroke of luck the tank's
interior is designed as if it's makers
intended for men to operate it with
various easily accessed storage cabinets
along the sides and ladder leading to a
hatch on the top abner was at a seat in
the front looking at an array of glass
panels suspended by mechanical
structures each panel glowed and
presented views from outside the tank
despite none of the panels being
connected to any wall or having any
movie projector he slowly experimented
with every button and mechanism
until we started moving forward
colliding into the tower
my memory of the next events is heavily
broken and trying to recall it brings on
intense mental pains abner began ramming
against the tower while pushing with the
tank's claws to make it topple
and with each thud i heard the voice of
richard it shouted at me telling me that
i was idiotic and with every collision
it screamed louder to call me a murderer
and a killer of humanity's future why do
i write it in capitals the last i
remember was the voice
sobbing
the next moment i can remember is us
driving away from the tower which had
just collapsed and crushed the cave
through the panels i can now see massive
gashes in the tower's exterior flashing
impossibly vibrant colours the next
several hours have been silent
reminiscing i've told abner to drive
faster as i know this cannot be a safe
object to be around
abda beckoned the two of us over to see
what was happening on the panels the
colours from the tower had grown bright
enough to be like the rising sun and the
surrounding snow and rocks were being
lifted into the air around it i then
witnessed a sight i cannot stop thinking
about a number of large black tendrils
pushed out of the ruins of the cave and
began pulling the tower into the snow it
was as if the tunnel had come to life
and needed something that was in that
infernal pillar
there was a violent explosion soon after
i felt the entire vehicle get lifted
into the air and thrown back down which
we think has broken one of palmer's ribs
from a collision with the ladder looking
outside now the site where we had been
is now a white inferno illuminating the
sky and creating the illusion of a sunny
day
we were driving when we heard a loud wet
slam come from right outside the vehicle
i opened the hatch to look out and lo
and behold richard had come for a visit
his torso was little more than an
amalgam of metal pulling itself through
the snow with three broken arms a comet
trail of pink and red blood stretching
out of the crater he made in the snow i
ordered abner to stop driving but he
kept at the wheel not even making eye
contact with me he didn't even consider
how important this was i yelled as much
as i could until the full stopped
i went to sit by richard as two
wound-shaped mouths began babbling like
a dying phonograph i caressed its head
never have i seen metal crumple so much
beneath single presses whispered
apologies to the holes in its face and
swung my axe down
over and over
not a word has been spoken since i
returned
i remember my departure from england how
i spoke of being able to witness
grandeur none in my village would ever
see
sure enough i have seen a world no other
man will come to witness one that puts
amundsen's kiddie sightseeing to shame
if the map this machine shows is to
believed we are getting closer to our
destination by the second i never needed
abner to drive
sadly my ink has nearly run out and my
pencils mere stubs so my entries on
what's left of the journey will be far
less frequent
for the crew members who have died
i am sorry and i do not ask that you
forgive me
i will continue in your honor
i will reach this damned pole and may
god cast me out of heaven if i don't
notably a ring-shaped stain of
hemorrhoids in is present on the upper
left corner of this page
no further entries are present
the journal and photographs were
discovered after mobile task force psy-1
located the tank vehicle of bannard and
the remaining crew in july of 2000 11
kilometers away from the south pole
although the tank had retained power and
heating due to its anomalous power
source one of the treads had been
heavily damaged and prevented continued
movement
inside the tank was the decayed cadaver
of a male human who had expired from
repeated penetrations on the body
matching those caused by an ice axe the
identity of the cadaver has not been
determined
the fate of the bannered crew is unknown
addendum 4431 3 south pole incident
on 2009 2019 severe seismic activity
occurred at the site of the geographic
south pole the ammons in scot south pole
station only experienced minor damages
but its crew reported the emergence of
an unknown rocky spire 51 meters from
the station foundation assets were
scrambled to the area
excavation of the rocky spire found that
it extends for an approximate depth of
40 meters into the antarctic plateau
however fragments composed of its
material extend for far deeper with the
lowest at a depth of 110 meters it is
considered likely that the fragments
stretch to the antarctic bedrock the
upper portion of the spire contains the
remnants of a tube similar to scp-4431
though at a width at which a human
individual could fit inside with
moderate difficulty broken pieces of an
ice axe blade surround the tube and a
bloody coat is embedded into the spire
nearby
a compacted soil-like substance
designated scp-4431-d
comprises the spire materials such as
ice and rock that come into contact with
scp-4431d
are gradually converted into further
scp-4431-d
the means by which this is achieved are
unclear but presumed to involve
alterations to the subatomic structure
of contacting materials
visual details match those of the soil
described in banner's journal trace
amounts of human gene sequences have
been found within the compounds
the excavation of past sites of
scp-4431-a
seismic activity is considered a high
priority
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zolfax 99
ianj alsup
zargaran professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
talk of villagers
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
african submarine vore
amir saban
seventy
kristoff kozak zlazak
hms lily
the almighty fish gav the clumsy
containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
sciodio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock
eric corbage
longinus
james saba
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you